voilà bah c'est un chat c'est la maison
du bonheur dans cette grande bâtisse
flambant neuf cette femme en situation
de handicap mental cohabitent dans un
esprit familial chacune dispose de sa
propre chambre et salle de bain le salon
la buanderie ou encore la cuisine sont
eux des lieux communs
du grand
theft auto ces démarches armes qui ont
beaucoup c'est une pièce plus si
important dans l'addition est pas que ce
n'est pas par chance le targa et si
l'univers c'est mon espace le même temps
elle piétine et après elles partent
elles partent pour pour aller travailler
elle travaille toute la journée en
revanche leur handicap ne leur permet
pas de vivre seule dans une danse en
appartement de pendant deux maîtresses
de maison aussi éducatrice spécialisée
ce relais pour les superviser faire le
lien avec les familles et proposer des
activités jardinage jeux de société
tâches ménagères les sept colocataires
participe pleinement à la vie
quotidienne le jardin a fait divers
puisque quand on se dépense on se
défoule en faisait un voyage on oublie
préfet cement
on va les accompagner pour pleut tout le
quotidien fait refaire la cuisine avec
elle le rappelait les services certain
jimmy et récupérer le courrier certains
de la cuisine et de la vaisselle matin
et soir une maison qui a comme objectif
de leur offrir un maximum d'autonomie
tout en brisant l'isolément liées au
handicap
c'est comme une famille normale comme
chez papa maman s'est pareillement on
peut vivre
à treillières on peut pas taillé en
quand je vois du vivre en sauver une
horrible plaire au fait des choses
rigolotes une colocation ce qui est
sympa c'est d'être avec ses amis de
pouvoir partager des vies des rois des
moments combiné aux pas se retrouver
tout seul le soir pour dîner un habitat
à taille humaine qui se présente comme
une alternative au foyer ou aux
instituts spécialisés
une colocation du même style existent
également pour cette jeune garçon à
versailles